numbers of course it's an interesting
question certainly we use the term
resurgence
we use the term revival and I think you
have read article by Peter Berger the
secularization of the world the dhih
dhih secularization of the world but as
they imply that there was a process of
secularization that somehow now has been
halted and is going in Reverse I think
this is the wrong way of looking at it
if as I said the religious and the
secular actually mutually constituted in
the process of modernization but
mutually consider differently then the
question is how they are constituted now
we in the West counted numbers because
this was part of our model of of
religion but in China in East Asia Japan
in in in China in Korea they didn't
count if you ask them even today if you
ask Chinese immigrants as they come to
to to the states with religion you are
Buddhist confusion now is Kris none oh
no religious no no this person may have
worship to the ancestors they altar at
home may have gone to a Buddhist temple
on the way to work and may have have
entered a church after work but no
religion you may have heard the name
Tomoko Misawa is the author of the
invention of the world religions we know
from from reconstruction that Hinduism
is a product of 19th century
Orientalists that then was taken by the
Hindus so they today 99% of P or people
from the Hindu tradition will know that
they are Hindus and they call themselves
Hindu so you couldn't count how many
Hindus there are but when it comes to
Chinese you cannot count and yet I
mentioned her name because she said well
my father when I went to the United
States he told me when they ask you
words to a religion say you are a
Buddhist in America you are supposed to
have some religion and more and more in
the warm people are supposed to have
some religion part of the process of
becoming a modern individual is to have
a religion but so rather than the
European model that we can modern you
abandon the church become an Church in
the rest of the world part of the
process becoming a mother individual
adopting a religious kind of identity
and so counting is a difficult and
complicated they try to count but we
don't know whether it means more than
before certainly something else so what
is happening religion is being
transformed is like in the United States
if it's not that religion has somehow
persisted or that somehow there was a
crash and then was revived simply it was
transformed and it was almost originated
as part of the process of modernization
so actually it's only in Europe that
modernization is accompanied with
religious decline almost everywhere else
is a complement with religion emerging
for the first time as a category
interestingly enough for instance there
are very famous scholars of religion
religious studies that say the category
of religion is so meaningless it means
so many different things that we should
get rid of the category altogether this
Christian category we should abandon is
a modern invention is helpless well it's
too late everybody uses the category
every Constitution in the world talks a
freedom of religion freedom to believe
not to believe journalists go around the
world asking people in an opinion public
opinion surveys asking people their
religion and precisely as everybody has
like the small child in East Berlin goes
home and ask mommy what is my religion
my Muslim children in school tell me you
have no religion and so becomes somehow
in this context dynamic of so resurgence
we don't see any restorations where you
have really secularization in you did
not have religious revival but what you
have is a post secular mentality the
realization the you cannot be simply
Unruh flexibly secular then you need to
think why you are securing the rest of
the people who saw religious and so
rather than being the natural outcome
modernization Europeans have to know for
the first time reflect upon their own
secularity in a way in which they didn't
before and this is precisely Habermas
the post secular habermas however much
much delay
theories of secular modernity and now
he's the one talking of post secular
societies in Europe not because
Europeans are religious again they are
not and they are more secular rebel but
they said but religion has become a very
contentious issue in every European
society so this is part of how she
transformed well we see we see to a
certain extent a process of Protestant
if equation and Americanization of
religion going on everywhere to assent
the forms of modern religion that were
invented by Protestantism individualism
you have oppressive individualization in
all world religions in Hinduism within
Buddhism is not only that it has become
Buddhism has become engaged with the
world so become it was always
individualistic in terms of mystic but I
kind of the need for every Buddhist
individual to somehow determine his or
her own religion second congregational
you have now congregational Hinduism it
never existed in history you have
congregational Buddhism it never existed
in history another in the Diaspora also
in India and in Korea and so on this is
interesting because precisely the
fundamental proposition of the social
science was that religion will disappear
in modernity precisely because religion
was tied to community a mineshaft
but modernity was great cells of society
the famous classic book from Ferdinand
tennis the minds of castles of from
personal relations to impersonal massive
and in this context there is no room for
community
this was the European idea that
urbanization is a matter of the salsa
the dress no room for our religious
community what happened was of course
that the religious communities that
existed in you know we're territorial
parishes as people go to the cities
there are no territorial parishes and
they didn't find a way of finding
congregations so yes Bureau has no
religious congregations only less
territorial parishes but in America as
the first thing people did immigrants
establish religious congregations and so
it is not a transformation is not a
transference of the European territorial
parents
those are voluntary
which are the form of modern communities
and we are saying everywhere the
explosion of the mosque the masks
movement that's in Cairo that has been
so analyzed thousands of thousands of
new masks emerging a simply deformation
of his more groups establishing their
own Muslim community very often women
there are of women in establishing
religious congregations is central in
all the religious traditions today so
you have certain aspects there there is
what I call this global
denominationalism the fact that if I am
a Muslim your is not only Christian
versus Islam is Hindu Muslim the whole
dynamic of Hinduism and Islam and how
much they affect and interact and
somehow even transform each other for
this interaction so is the way in which
is not only Buddhism going Western is
Western religious were in Buddhist I
mean we know the influence of
spirituality how many people's are my
spiritual not religious and business of
spirituality within that I to
institutional ecclesiastical religions
is also linked to this notion of Eastern
spirituality and so on so you have a
kind of global flows of religious
transformations which are affecting all
religions in different ways